man to my right always enjoy chatting
with one of the biggest Seattle sports
fans that we've met here in Los Angeles
Dave made a maze hits theaters and
video-on-demand including right here on
DirecTV on August 18th he plays Dave in
Dave made amazed Nick soon good to see
you sir and you can buy it on iTunes or
you can pre-order it right now yeah like
as so basically why wouldn't you just
click over watch you know you get your
show on this screen and get a new tab
open it's a multiple screen world which
we live Nick so I don't know what I mean
I'd love to chat with you about your
Seattle Seahawks in your Mariners but
you have given me a heads up that you
have an incredible story sports related
story yeah similar to the one how sports
related it is okay okay good enough well
I mean last time you were here you told
a story about how I went into an office
therapists office and Ray Liotta stroll
down and great I mean that's the short
version of it yeah that's a very short
name it's basically the story of my best
acting scene I've ever had and that's
living on our app and we should be able
to that yes exactly so you have the
floor this is involved not going to say
I'm actually outfit that I'm wearing
right now is the outfit that I wore
moving I moved all day yesterday and I
just the only shirt that I had was merch
of mine that I found in the garage a
team and a t-shirt that says Nixon good
guy on it and that you can buy my
website okay so you were tall so I moved
my son had a black eye he ran into a
table yesterday he's supposed to bubble
wrap those things when you move you know
what I mean and so we basically pulled
into a neighborhood as new residents and
I'm wearing a shirt with my face on it
your name and my son has a black eye and
I thought the best thing we could do is
just say we're fostering him or
everyone's just getting like well is a
he's a good guy or you live in Los
Angeles so neglectful parroted was wrong
I ain't a neglectful parent was a clear
narcissist here sitting in Los Angeles
so people don't even mind that so the
Dodgers I mean I I feel like I had to
explain the fact I'm a huge Mariners fan
it always will be till I die
well you threw out a first pitch for
this yet Edwards you put together which
we make dreams happen yeah we realize
you don't really do that I love baseball
and I
so close to Dodger Stadium for so long I
invested in season tickets fantastic and
that's a great way to put it invested in
season tickets in this day and age how
much these things call I'm gonna make so
much money for exactly the amount of
Dodger dogs I've eaten yes I mean I know
the place to get the grill Dodger dogs
by the way which a lot of people don't
know when you go to long Dodger Stadium
yeah I'm not going to get that on air
though yeah I want to keep that a secret
one location sure but so I had eight
friends in town from out of you know
Portland Seattle and I contacted all the
people around me with season tickets and
bought their tickets for that game and
so I brought my friends on a Saturday
night great game one everybody was happy
was a big win and my friend drove all of
us in a 1989 Ford Bronco which if you
know that it's a two-door and eight
people legally are not allowed to be in
that but we were and the game was over
and we got back in the Ford Bronco and
if you've been to Dodger Stadium on a
Saturday night you know that it's
impossible to get out of especially if
you stay for the whole game and so we're
in a cattle herd we're just trying to
get out we're listening to music
everyone's having a good time I am
mandated Nick soon to ask what color
this Ford Bronco was it's navy blue ok
very good
except there is a brown stripe along the
side ok but only a two-toned it is not
white oh no but I'll tell you what
though that's way soon as I heard Ford
Bronco and I heard Los Angeles and I
heard a sports scene I'm like that's
where this is you know that my friend
the next day Tech after the story tags
me a picture of OJ and said this is
Astra so ok so that's point B and we're
sitting here at Point a okay what are we
out here half hour of traffic we're
almost to the Elysian this we're almost
to the exit of Vin Scully Street exit
we've got about a hundred yards to go
yes and I say to my friend listen you're
not allowed to take a ride up here but
if you get over the right lane just
don't even listen to him just take the
right and so he goes to do that and then
he rear ends the car in front of us it
is a brand new black SUV beautiful car
I'm not going to mention the brand sure
and at that moment it's like oh my god
you just hit somebody and we're in this
is we're going to
in trouble the cops are going to be
involved and then two people get out
first we see a girl out of the front
passenger seat then we see Corey Seager
get out of the driver's seat Corey
Seager gets out of his car he hit a home
run in the first inning Corey Seager is
Kyle Seager I love Corey Seager your
brother of one of the best Mariners of
razuna know about the third brother by
the way there is a third so and his
parents are so good-looking I mean the
whole family just beautiful and but
Corey's the most beautiful little boy
I've ever seen in my life gets out of
this car comes around he's wearing an
Under Armor shirt he just hit a home run
he just played nine innings and he's
just with the herd leaving the game and
he goes back and he looks we broke a
taillight he looks at it looks at the
girl and he realizes that he is now in a
moment where he might people are going
to start with his kursi her right your
Rookie of the Year he looks at it and
realized the situation looks back at us
and goes you just don't Salkin on the
way to the car we're just like silent
and I go out the window
great game Corey and the girl laughed
out loud got back in the car and
literally we could have hit anyone else
in that exit and we would have been
dealing with the cops
yes exchanging of information but we hit
corey seager and here is the thing that
breaks my heart
the thing that breaks my heart is the
next day he went over 400 and it makes
me think was there
whiplash did awesome he didn't want to
talk to the coaches about it you did you
just you just did enough contact to
damage a taillight right that's it
that's a bit I mean he went over for I
don't know you do the math yeah yeah he
didn't do good for two games and then he
came back with a home run but I loved
them and I would live the rest of my
life with him of like a nick soon that
is a wild story because you'd think that
a Dodger player would have some way of
getting out you think there's awesome
exit but but you just also telling the
story the fact that you get in the car
after a game and you're like eight
people and you're like and a half hour
later we're just getting to the edge of
the parking lot just that
I'm telling you that's why people you
know they make fun of Dodger fans about
leaving the game early I mean you really
have to to get the hell oh my god
yeah and Corey Seager though has no
choice he's playing all 9 innings but
I'm in that I'm in like the reserve
section so it's all season
ticket-holders if you walk out in the
seventh inning yeah you'd be like no I'm
just going to get a hot dog yeah
people who like sellout you're right
believe you don't want to watch it
that's funny man so I guess rookie
contracts man it's just a taillight I
don't need to get in it I mean but is
there a more fun team to watch right now
than the Dodgers well there's 79 and 31
mitch has never had 32 18:12 right I
mean it's it's insane what they're doing
right now
ridiculous and they've lost only one
game since Clayton Kershaw went on the
disabled list and here's the one so as
far as the Seahawks go when they won the
Super Bowl I was in the last place that
I lived and then we moved and then we
know what happened with the Patriots and
then we know what happened last year and
now I moved again and I think well
they're back baby I'm in a new house so
it's bit with the Dodgers I'm moving
this time of year I mean I don't want
people to you know attack me on Twitter
but if things go downhill from here it's
not on me and they sent that next phone
on Twitter but you I think the fact that
whatever might be in play
superstitiously mean with the Dodgers
you have completely blown off kilter by
rear-ending Corey Seager on the way out
of the game and you know I mean legally
I couldn't he could now approach me and
say and I was a passenger I was not the
driver there were eight passengers in
the car but only 55 you know there's a
lot of legal issues here if there was
only a legal limit of if there was a
legal number of people in the Ford
Bronco there might have been less weight
and thus maybe never even hit on to
acting do you think about that or maybe
if I didn't tell him to get in the right
lane and take an illegal right turn
that's that my dad who doesn't do that
trying to get out of Dodge I mean
seriously if we do follow them at any
place if you haven't left a parking lot
after game after half an hour
you begin to consider it on a Saturday
normally wouldn't yeah you just wouldn't
do that
but the attendance at Dodger Stadium
even on a weekday I think
more than any other stadium so Dave made
amazed is that about this story me
trying to get away from course just no
getting out of a parking lot is oh it is
it's mean technically yeah yeah we shot
the movie in Glendale in three weeks I
mean it was it the movie is insane the
real main character of the movie isn't
David's the maze it's that the art is
just amazing that's what really comes
out of it okay and people can go and get
it on iTunes should write a cage be in
select cities and theatres on demand
right here on DirecTV and I've been
going around and doing like little Q&A
after screenings people love it that's
great
phenomenal feels good to be involved in
a quality project what do you think
before I let you go do you think of your
Seahawks in all seriousness and I told
you I'm moving I feel good about I moved
because of what's been going on it's bit
you know Doug Baldwin said Russ is
coming back he's skinny people are
impressed
it also Baldwin called him fat mmm said
last year that he would be these guys
you're simply doing they are just
they're there one there like one wacky
family yeah and assuming they are I'm so
glad Sherman didn't get traded because
he to me is he's my favorite athlete to
watch because he just has an opinion and
he just doesn't care I mean he he's not
afraid to say what he thinks about the
NFL he's not afraid to say what he
thinks about Kaepernick and I can't
respect anybody more than him yeah I'm
with you and I think that they're
they're as good as ever I really believe
that I mean getting Cam getting that
money like I remember two years ago that
was an issue he held out and everybody
thought uh you know I think they are I
think they're as good as ever
and I know that's saying a lot cuz
marshawn's not back there I'm so glad
marshawn's back in the NFL me too I
can't wait to watch him I don't care
he's not on our team anymore I agree
with I love him I cannot tell one story
about gun you got my friend who's a
Panthers fan who actually signed me up
for the Panthers email list to be a new
drummer for their band because he hates
me that much happened to be in Oakland
that's a great I get a lot of email by
the way it's a lot II but hey the
marching band coming back bit my friend
was in Oakland and he sent me a picture
of Marshawn Lynch's store beast mode and
he sent me the picture and said hey
guess where I am and I said buy me
something he said never
and then he called me five minutes later
and says you're never gonna believe what
just happened Marshawn Lynch walked out
of the beast mode store across the
street into Starbucks bought a mocha
which he followed him like you I wanna
see what he's ordering who knew who's a
mocha fan but he came out and there was
a homeless kid out on the sidewalk and
he with his mocha went back into the
store grab the first sweatshirt on the
rack and just ripped it off walked out
of the store through to the kid got in
his car and took off marshawn's the best
man he's great he's great for the game
and he's gonna be great for Oakland and
I wish I would have been in walking the
Starbucks just to see how the barista
botched spelling his name inside of his
coffee that'd be great good to see you
Nick soon yeah thank you for having me
you got at Nick soon on Twitter Thu and
E and make sure you check out Dave made
amazing theaters video-on-demand iTunes
August 18th come back anytime brother
good luck with that love it thank you
gotta and BB and I'm glad we sent a car
for you right of course okay cuz if you
drove yourself I'd warn everybody in the
drunk in the parking lot under the dry
very careful the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to